on our website booktv.org
and now on book tv we're live with
author and radio host eric mataxis
mr mataxis is the author of many books
including everything you always wanted
to know about god but were afraid to ask
bonhoeffer pastor martyr prophet spy
and if you can keep it the forgotten
promise of american liberty
eric mataxis in your current book if you
can keep it you talk about the golden
triangle of freedom what is that
you're just leaping right in aren't you
uh hi peter
i have to tell you um people always ask
me how i write my books and
this book if you can keep it which is my
newest book the the book on luther is
coming out in just a couple of weeks but
this book for the last year i've been
talking about america and at the very
heart of it is this concept of the
golden triangle of freedom
but what i find funny is that i'd never
heard of it no one's ever heard of it
a number of years ago a dear friend of
mine oz guinness wrote a book called a
free people's suicide in which he
centers on this issue that he calls the
golden triangle of freedom and when i
understood it
i just about went nuts i said how is it
possible that i've never heard this
every one of the founders every single
one benjamin franklin jefferson every
one of them understood this concept
and when osgenes book came out i thought
i've got to do more to get this out
there because you know one book comes
out
um so i didn't know that i'd write a
book about it i thought i wrote an op-ed
or something like that but it ended up
being a book and the golden triangle of
freedom
should i explain it briefly
again all the founders understood this
quickly it's that
freedom requires virtue now when we say
freedom we mean self-government requires
virtue virtue in turn requires faith and
then faith in turn requires freedom so
to explain it
the founders said they wrote this over
and over and over
you can't have self-government you can't
have actual freedom unless the people
govern themselves which is to say unless
the people have some
semblance of virtue
you can't force people to govern
themselves it's free will if you want to
govern yourself it has to come from your
inner virtue they wrote about this over
and over and over growing up in america
i never heard this once i grew up in
good american schools went to yale i
mean i never heard this concept of
virtue
connected to freedom
and then the founder said and virtue by
the way
really needs to be married to faith not
in every case but typically it had been
their observation and this is what i
find funny it was their observation
franklin observed then when george
whitefield preached
people
would find faith they'd get excited
about faith and their virtue would rise
in other words crime would go down
alcoholism would go down they all the
founders understood that those kind of
people can govern themselves so you
don't need to be a christian but the
point is virtue and faith are connected
they want to promote virtue and faith
but the final piece and this is what
makes america
i would say the greatest nation in the
world
we say that faith is important but it
must be free
if the government in any way tries to
coerce faith or
lack of faith or the type of faith it
all breaks down true faith has to be
completely free so in my luther book i
talk about you know the catholics try to
force everybody to catholic the
protestants tries force everybody to be
protestant luther wanted to get the jews
out of saxony religious freedom is a
fairly new idea the founders understood
that in order for this to work for
freedom and faith to flourish for virtue
to flourish
freedom
has to be religious freedom at the core
and if the people are allowed to choose
whether they go to church whether they
go to synagogue where they go if it's
completely free only then it can work
that in a nutshell is the golden
triangle of freedom and i thought to
myself every american
must understand this because without
that
we can't be america and you go on to
quote john adams is saying our
constitution was made only for a moral
and religious people well the funny
thing is many people have heard the
adams quote
that's one of dozens of quotes many of
the founders you'd never know that they
talked about this benjamin franklin
washington they all talked about the
link between virtue and freedom
the fact that virtue is never spoken
about today in the public schools i mean
if you're going to teach kids about
america in american public schools paid
for with american tax dollars
you need to tell them how this is
supposed to work and when i say that all
of the founders said this i mean all of
the founders there there was not any of
them
who thought well there are other ways as
far as they was concerned they were
concerned there were no other ways if
the people don't have virtue and again
it doesn't mean every person but
generally speaking if there is not
virtue and an ability to govern yourself
if those uh
instincts those muscles aren't developed
you cannot have self-government you go
back to tyranny whether it's monarchy or
bureaucracy
no matter what
that has to happen so the fact that this
has not been taught roughly for 40 years
since i've been you know a kid
we've we've walked away from the idea of
virtue it makes us uncomfortable that
has
really destroyed america and i don't say
that as a partisan i say that as an
american if you care about freedom you
have to care about this concept you have
to understand it i wrote the book by the
way peter i got to say i wrote the book
for everybody this is not a book for
conservatives this is not a book for
hardcore patriots or tea party people
this is a book that left and right
richard dreyfuss is big on this issue
people need to understand that there's
some things that are non-negotiable the
stuff in this book is non-negotiable for
every american how you play it out
that's up to you but if you're not
teaching this in the schools we've lost
a couple of generations and i think
we're in big trouble and in your book if
you can keep it eric mataxis you write
about your time at yale
and you say that
how could i have grown up in a world
that no longer valued this great
treasure this great treasure being paul
revere's ride the poem by henry
wadsworth yeah well there are a couple
of things i mean there's polar bears
right i i have to say that because my
parents are immigrants my dad came from
greece war-torn greece more than
war-torn doubly war-torn they had the
greek civil war after world war ii they
had an earthquake
he appreciated america he loved america
he loves america today i hope he's
watching my mom came from war-torn
germany lost her father in the war
people who come from outside this
country typically have a better view
of what we have here i talk to cab
drivers all the time in new york city
most of them immigrants most of them
rave about how great america is and i
thought
if you understand
what we have and how fragile it is this
is not to say there aren't problems and
i write about that in the book but the
point is that first you have to see that
what we have is incredibly special
incredibly fragile if we don't shore it
up and take care of it it simply goes
away and one of the things in my book if
you can keep it i suggest must be done
is you have to teach young people
the stories the myths the heroes you
have to celebrate george washington and
paul revere and nathan hale if you don't
do that something's sick in every
culture i mean growing up with my dad
being greek i would hear about the greek
heroes they would rave about you know
greek independence
that's called normal you're supposed to
be proud of your culture in american
culture something happened in the 40s we
stopped doing that so the story of paul
revere's ride
because it's by henry wadsworth
longfellow he's not a modernist poet you
know he's not a a multicultural poet
he's a 19th century white male poet well
paul reveres writes one of the greatest
poems ever written one of the most
beautiful poems ever written and i
decided to memorize it with my daughter
when she was eight so that's ten years
ago
i i was embarrassed that i didn't know
the poem and i would get tears in my
eyes because i said people literally
sacrificed their lives so i could sit in
this comfortable house and think
whatever i want
we need to teach that to our kids and so
i did a thing on my radio program where
i challenged people to memorize paul
revere's writes a long
poem but we got tons of submissions on
youtube and it's just part of what i
want to do i want to get people excited
about who we are
and the chapter loving america you asked
the first question to ask is how can we
plausibly be expected to love a country
we know to be guilty of so many things
right well this is the question and this
is why unfortunately because most tv
programs aren't like this one it's all
about sound bites it's all about gotcha
gotcha gotcha the fact of the matter is
any fool knows that love is not binary
okay if you love your kid it doesn't
mean you approve of everything your kid
does in fact if you really love your kid
you might be really hard on your kid
because you want your kid not to make
the mistakes you made so when you love
your country that never means america
love it or leave it it means
if you love it you celebrate what's good
and you look seriously at what's wrong
and you try to fix it now that's to me
normal and healthy but i kind of think
of it this way it's almost like let's
say you have a kid that's bad and you're
having trouble with the kid imagine if
the parent instead of saying i'm going
to try to love this kid in the right
direction i'm going to correct this kid
i'm going to correct this kid hard and
i'm gonna love this kid and encourage
the good behavior and i hope this kid
goes on the right path what if the
parent says you know what you're bad
you're bad you're never gonna amount to
anything you're basically cursing the
kid right you're saying you're never
gonna amount to anything and the kid
says well i did this i was like you know
what i don't care it's too late and it
was if you have that attitude some
towards somebody that's the antithesis
of love that's judgment right you judge
somebody in in such a harsh way that no
matter what they do
they can never redeem themselves and i
think a narrative entered
american public life roughly in the 60s
where we began to deal seriously as we
should
with civil rights and slavery and how we
dealt with the native americans we dealt
with that stuff in a way for the first
time but something happened where we
never were able to let it go in other
words we you keep throwing it back in
the face it's kind of like we're in a
marriage you throw something back in
somebody's face over and over and over
so that they can never get past it you
can never say you know what you've
worked on that i appreciate the fact
that you've worked on that we're not
there yet
but that kind of attitude if you keep
harping on the negative it creates a
narrative which has taken
hold
in public school teaching certainly in
colleges i can't a kind of anti-american
sentiment which is actually really
unhealthy and is causing america to be
stuck uh in some of the ruts where we've
been stuck
the almost chosen people is a chapter in
your book and you write to some extent
this is a book about what's been called
american exceptional
exceptionalism right
which is
rightly and wrongly something of a
controversial subject oh yeah because
most people misunderstand the concept of
american exceptionalism right it's the
same idea of when you say the jews are
god's chosen people
when you're chosen by god you don't
click your heels and go ha ha we're
chosen you're not it's just the opposite
you are chosen
for something grim and serious you're
chosen for a mission the jews were
chosen by god if you're a christian as i
am
you believe that they're chosen for a
mission it's going to be hard this is
not a fun thing
lincoln whom we revere referred to
america as god's almost chosen people he
didn't want to be blasphemous since they
were god's chosen people but he said
that there's something unique now again
this is lincoln okay this is lincoln he
said there's something unique in america
something really special
but it's a burden it's a responsibility
and it's a responsibility to the whole
world so what i say is the only reason i
would ever say that america is great or
exceptional is because america is the
one nation in the world
that has for over two centuries
explicitly existed for others
where it's not about us it's about how
do we spread our freedom how do we
spread our freedom and give people in
the soviet gulag hope in the 1980s how
do we give
people the ability to come to this
country we've always been a nation of
immigrants now we get in arguments about
the details but nobody denies
that we have always been outward focused
we have never said if you don't have a
certain
ethnic background or a certain color
you're not welcome here what makes this
country crazy amazing is that my parents
who have accents to this day
they are as american as george
washington there's no country in the
world
that is an idea it's an idea that says
if you buy into these ideas you can be
as american as anyone who ever lived but
it's only because i want to stress this
because we're supposed to exist for
others we're supposed to care about the
rest of the world and i would say
throughout our history america has cared
about the rest world i'm not going to
pretend we're perfect but we have gone
out of our way
uh to take responsibility just the way
kind of like a like the big kid uh in
the school yard says like i'm a big kid
so i'm going to defend the week if i can
i kind of have responsibility do i have
to know i choose to do that i really
think that's been the dna of america and
even now with the flood the harvey flood
people go aren't people great i would
actually say no americans are great why
because there are plenty places around
the world that experience devastation
but it's not part of their culture i'm
not talking about their dna the people
are the same but there's something in
american culture about giving back
about helping your neighbor those are
biblical ideas that have taken root in
the west in part thanks to wilberforce
and others but to pretend that every
every person in the world behaves like
that when tragedy strikes a lot of times
when tragedy strikes it's about me how
can i survive there's something in the
american culture that we've had for over
200 years and the common man and woman
has not lost this that we care about our
neighbors somehow we know it's the right
thing to do that's to me what make what
makes america special is we we actually
care about the other guy we care when 9
11 happened
we cared about muslims being persecuted
that's amazing i mean what a beautiful
thing that we cared about that it wasn't
just like hey we're going to kick butt
all right we're going to we're going to
wipe out
i mean there's that side of it but
there's another side that says but hold
on they're really good people my
neighbor i know is muslim i don't want
my neighbor to think that i hate him
that's america that's that is beautiful
we need to we need to celebrate it well
before we go any further eric mataxis a
couple of names you've mentioned let's
get some uh clarification oz guinness
yeah
osgoon as he became a friend about 20
years ago he's a great man a great
writer a great thinker
i recommend his book a free people
suicide more than any other book
it is a sobering
uh glorious
pen to
uh american freedom and it it explains
uh through the founders and through
tookville and through lincoln as i try
to do in my book not as well
what it is that we have and what we must
do
to preserve it but oz guinness is a a
real intellectual he's written many
books and i would recommend to anybody
anything he's ever written check it out
he's a rare bird
george whitfield
george whitfield he's another one of
these characters i say these things over
and over about how half of my career is
being embarrassed i'm goaded by being
embarrassed when i discovered who george
whitefield was
i thought to myself there's something
really sick with this country that we're
not teaching young people who george
whitfield is i mean he's as important as
any of the founders period case closed
he was an evangelist
who came here from england he was about
21 years old
he preached like a maniac i mean he
makes the apostle paul and billy graham
look lazy and i'm not even kidding
he was
a force of nature unlike we've ever seen
but here's the key
he wasn't just preaching about jesus
although he was but he was preaching
about the freedom of the gospel and he
was explaining to people and this is
luther talks about this but whitfield
really brought this to the colonies this
idea that
your first responsibility is to god so
if your preacher is not preaching the
truth go to another church if your
magistrate your governor your leaders
are not speaking the truth you hold them
to account everyone is equal under god
that's a radical idea
everyone is equal
the guy with the powdered wig the guy uh
hoeing in the field
we're all equal because we're all under
god
that's of course at the heart of
american liberty the founders and the
framers put it in our founding documents
but if not for whitfield
for literally four or five decades
preaching this like crazy up and down
the colonies it would have not been
imbibed it would have not trickled down
to the common man so by the time you
have the 1770s when whitfield passed
away you have a people in america who so
understand this idea of this kind of
american egalitarianism
that they are ready to govern themselves
and that's why the founders
saw this and they said these people are
ready if we hand them freedom
they may be able to govern themselves if
you hand people freedom in iraq or
afghanistan you see that if they're not
prepared it doesn't just happen it's not
like you topple the dictator and tricorn
hats and muskets and constitutions pop
up that's not normal we need to be
educated and trained how to govern
ourselves it's a rare and a fragile
thing and again that's why i feel if we
don't teach this stuff now we lose it in
fact we are losing it what was uh
george whitfield's connection to ben
franklin oh this is hilarious whitfield
was i mean he was such a phenomenon he
had they say by the time he died this is
hard to believe but this is true by the
time he died 80 percent
of all the people in the colonies had
heard him preach in person at least one
time so he was he saturated the
continent before he even came here he
was famous in england he was drawing
crowds like looney crowds anybody in
high school if you read uh the
autobiography of ben franklin ben
franklin recounts as a young man
whitfield gets off the boat and preaches
and franklin being the sort of scientist
he decides to figure out how many people
are in the crowd how many people could
hear his voice
and franklin decided that yes about 30
000 people could hear him preaching
without a microphone of course
microphones weren't invented so franklin
had a connection with him franklin was
not like what i'd call an orthodox
christian but neither was he some kind
of atheist or even an agnostic i mean he
was a sort of
canny student of religion and he decided
to to publish
think of if this happened today he
decided to publish all of whitfield's
sermons
in the pennsylvania gazette this is
before whitfield came to america and
then when whitfield came to america he
became his publisher so imagine he had
the ability to publish tons of sermons
he was himself not a born-again
evangelical but he said what this man is
doing what the effect this man is having
is so positive i want to do everything i
can to help him so they became friends
over the years and they really were
friends their whole lives
good afternoon and welcome to book tv on
c-span 2 this is our monthly in-depth
program where we have one author on to
talk about his or her body of work this
month it's best-selling author and radio
talk show host eric mataxis mr mataxis
began writing books in 1995 the birthday
abc which is a children's book his first
adult book was don't you believe it an
actual parody came out in 96
bible abc in 98 squanto in the miracle
of thanksgiving in 99 several children's
books
everything you always wanted to know
about god but were afraid to ask came
out in 2005
everything you always wanted to know
about god but were afraid to ask
second edition came out in 2007
uncle mugsy and the terrible twins of
christmas 2007 as well then amazing
grace william wilberforce in the heroic
campaign to end slavery
who was william wilberforce
you got me
oh i wrote a book about him i'm
responsible for this information uh
wilberforce is another one of these
figures i i hope i don't repeat this too
much but
when i learned who wilberforce was i got
embarrassed because i said everybody
needs to know who this is and i hardly
know who he is once again it was oz
guinness whom i mentioned along with
chuck colson
uh whom i had the privilege of uh
befriending later in life his life
who introduced me to the concept of
wilberforce the nutshell version of
wilberforce is that he was the man in
great britain
who decided that he must use his power
in parliament
to end the slave trade now
when you know the details this is freaky
stuff the slave trade was about as
embedded in the economy of great britain
as anything conceivable
but he had a moral
issue he became a serious christian
wilberforce did around 1785 and he
almost instantly asked god what do you
want me to do get out of politics of
course i should get out of politics it's
so filthy and horrible i'll become a
preacher well he went to visit his
friend john newton who wrote
amazing grace
which is the title of my book and newton
said no stay in politics it seems that
god has prepared you
to be his vessel in politics so will
before stays in politics and in 1787
writes what became 20 famous words in
his diary he says god almighty has set
before me two great objects
uh the suppression of the slave trade
and the reformation of manners by
manners he meant morality or culture he
understood that great britain was a
hypocrite nation they called themselves
christians but they had the slave trade
they had every kind of abomination
treating people i mean we take this for
granted today that we've got to figure
out how to help the poor we argue do we
do it with tax dollars do we do with
private dollars we argue about how to
help the poor in those days no one
helped the poor they can just rot
wilberforce said god has called me into
politics number one to abolish the slave
trade and number two pretty much
everything else and so
he's a force
in in history that
if you don't know who he is
you're missing something huge because as
i say when i did the research i was
embarrassed almost daily because i
thought this guy changed the world in
which we live so dramatically i mean we
all think oh of course slavery's wrong
well when he was around nobody thought
slavery was wrong except him and a few
quakers and a few evangelical christians
like john wesley he dedicated himself he
said this is an abomination against god
god will not bless this nation if we
treat other human beings this way he
spent years and years and years the
victory was in 1807 and he did all kinds
of other stuff so he's one of my great
heroes can any politician
can he polly oh very i think if you're
not a candy politician you're not much
of a politician i think that see this is
the misunderstanding is a lot of people
think that if i'm going to be spiritual
or i'm going to be christian or i'm
going to follow god it means that i
become otherworldly
and i become
stupid when it comes to the things of
this world absolutely not
god shows us over and over he wants his
people to be real he wants people to
bring him into reality uh my luther book
ends up being about that is that there
was this false idea um
that had taken uh control in some ways
of the catholic church of luther's time
i i wouldn't say generally speaking but
in luther's time was this idea
that if you want to be holy you've got
to go into holy orders you've got to be
a monk you've got to pray all the time
you can't be holy as a housewife you
can't be holy
as a farmer
that idea
is simply unbiblical but there are many
people who are guilty of that many
people who are serious christians who
think i've got to be otherworldly and
float around like a ghost and i don't
deal with normal people's problems
god wants us to deal with normal
people's problems we're here to be
people we're not here to be ghosts or
we're not here to say i'm ready to go to
heaven uh tomorrow i'm not ready to go
until god calls me wilberforce
he got that and so he was
you know you've heard the term in this
in the world but not of it he was not of
the world i mean people couldn't make
sense of him why is he working with his
enemies for this or why is he doing that
i mean in a way he was a conundrum but
he was thoroughly in the world in the
sense that he says i'm going to do what
i need to do politically he he didn't
play
dirty pool i mean that's the other
amazing thing is you can be effective
without compromising in that way so
wilberforce to me he's the ultimate hero
in 2008 the book it's time to sleep my
love came out
everything you always wanted to know
about god the jesus edition in 2010
and bonhoeffer pastor martyr prophet and
spy bestseller came out in 2010 and mr
mataxis before this book came out you
wrote in your
further book seven men that i am far too
self-centered to want to spend several
years thinking about someone else i
never wanted to write a biography i mean
when i was at yale i was sure that i
would be a fiction writer and a humor
writer those were my two
goals i admired woody allen i admired
robert benchley
i admired you know sj pearlman i admired
cheever and updike and gabriel c marquez
and faulkner and i wanted to be
someone who wrote quote unquote art who
wrote humor
if you'd asked me in
2006 do you think he'll ever write a
biography i would have flat out said no
i just don't get it but something
happened where someone asked me to write
would you write a biography of william
wilberforce
and this is one of these things i don't
say about this this is like a religious
cliche but i prayed about it and god
spoke to me i won't get into the details
but it's one of these things that i say
because i want people to know that
that's possible it's in my case it's
quite rare but it was one of those
things i needed to know
whether i ought to spend all this time
work you know because to work on
something with all your might and main
uh
maine
you want to know that this is something
you ought to be doing so i wrote the
wilberforce book uh i was very proud of
it because it allowed me to
exercise my literary muscles in in a
sense to be literary to
enjoy writing because i love words
um and
when
people would say to me well you know
thanks for writing the wilberforce book
who are you going to write about next i
always said i don't want to write
another biography but but people kind of
wore me down and eventually
i thought if i were to write when it
would have to be bonhoeffer because
nobody rises to the level of wilberforce
the way bonhoeffer does i mean this is a
man who because of his faith
stands out in history you don't need to
be a person of faith to admire
bonhoeffer or wilberforce these are men
who were so great
by any standards unless you're a white
supremacist
that
you have to admire them and then when
you look deeper you see that
they were
those rare creatures who
really lived in the world they were
normal emotionally healthy funny amazing
human beings who had a deep faith and it
governed
their actions and i thought we live in a
culture where you typically don't
hear those kinds of stories very much i
think that's a shame because i think to
many people of faith in america are
there many people that are curious about
faith and if you never hear positive
stories you kind of get the impression
that people of faith are all religious
hypocrites you know and that's that's
simply not true and it's actually a
great injustice because there's so many
people leading quiet lives
um
uh what is this the last line from
middlemarch you know lives of quiet
desperation i mean there are people that
are just serving their families and
doing good and it comes out of their
faith and you don't hear that well these
are two
magnificent heroes whose stories i
thought were were little known
and whose stories really ought to be
well known
when did dietrich bonhoeffer start
protesting the nazis
well
it's hard to say basically uh
his family was an elite family in berlin
so already in the 20s
they were aware because the nazis
were
locally present in berlin
they were aware
of what the nazis were if you were
living on a farm uh in the middle of you
know
uh
central germany you really wouldn't know
who the nazis were they knew early on
that these are violent people these are
people who go into the streets with with
bats and uh they weren't wearing masks
in those days but the point is that
these are thuggish people they're
looking for trouble if they don't get
their way
they're going to uh they're going to
make physical violence they're going to
make trouble
the bonhoeffers saw this and they saw
hitler early on so in other words they
could smell who these people were they
weren't
uh bamboozled by the rhetoric
so i would say that that the bonhoeffer
family had their eyes on hitler and the
nazis way back what happened was um in
the
when hitler comes to power
in 33 early 33
they were already prepared
to work against him now again nobody in
33 understood that we're gonna have 12
years of this kind of stuff in death
camps i don't think there's anybody in
the nazi party that thought we're going
to have death camps this was something
that no one could foresee how far this
would go
but in 33
bonhoeffer and his family were secretly
already talking and having meetings now
they were planning
you know all kinds of things his father
was the top psychiatrist in germany so
they're they're lutheran they're not
jewish they're lutheran oh yeah well
they're they're they're
you know they're lutheran the way a lot
of germans are lutheran which is to say
they're not jewish maybe they're not
atheists but they weren't like faithful
lutherans bonhoeffer was himself his
mother was but i think the rest of the
family they were just cultural
christians you know um
his sister married a jew so you can see
that they weren't like really religious
right i mean she marries a man who is
you know he converted to christianity
but they were they were kind of cultural
christians but bonhoeffer and his mother
in particular were serious about their
faith and they had their eyes on the
nazis from the beginning but they were
trying
to plan uh other ways of getting the
nazis out of power it was only late in
the 30s
that he gets involved in the plot to
kill hitler his principal goal
and we're making a movie about this was
to get the church to stand against
hitler that was what he wanted he says
i'm a church man i'm a pastor i'm a
theologian
the church needs to stand up to this
wicked man but the church
did not understand it until it was too
late
a couple more books by by eric mataxis
socrates in the city came out in 2011
we'll talk about that a little bit later
seven men in 2013 miracles 2014
seven women in 2015.
if you can keep it the forgotten promise
of american liberty came out in 2016.
we've talked a little bit about that and
coming out next month martin luther the
man who rediscovered god and changed the
world
in your book seven men mr mataxis you
refer to charles colson as a hero oh
he was the real deal you know when you
spend time with somebody you can see
behind
the facade if there is a facade
i often say to people i mean i'm not
this is not original with me but if you
want to see proof of god you look at a
changed life chuck colson
was the dirty tricks guy
working for nixon he was convinced that
we need to do whatever we can to defeat
the opposition
and he was the one who reached out to
howard hunt and you know to to try to
get
some kind of an advantage in the
re-election in 72.
well
coulson was
brilliant i mean he was brilliant till
the day he died just a genius um
a real go-getter
and sometimes if you people give you
enough rope and you're strong enough you
know you you hang yourself with it he
pretty much got to a point where before
watergate broke he saw that his life was
empty his hard-charging personality had
ruined his marriage
he really was empty and